bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver au
Parlement européen à Bruxelles pour une
nouvelle émission d'Europe Hebdo
dernière ligne droite avant les
élections européennes vous le savez
c'est dimanche et dans ce numéro
direction l'Espagne et ses étudiants en
colère contre la politique d'austérité
de Madrid l'éducation nationale touché
de plein fouet là-bas la politique de
rigueur ce sont des bourses enans moins
ça fait sortir les étudiants dans la rue
c'est ce que nous allons voir tout à
l'heure mais avant faisons un tour
d'Europe des campagne européenne et on
commence avec la
Bulgarie rasovo en Bulgarie dans cette
région des hérité du nord-ouest du pays
les habitants estiment la vie était
meilleure du temps du bloc communiste et
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne est très
controversée nous voulons faire partie
de l'Europe et c'est le cas mais comment
se fait-il que le niveau de vie soit
tellement plus bas ici que dans les
autres
pays moins pessimiste en Pologne 10 ans
après son adhésion à l'Union européenne
le pays voit son agriculture profiter
grandement de la PAC la politique
agricole commune
nous vendons nos pommes dans toute
l'Europe nos pommes sont exportées de
Lisbonne jusqu'à loural et même jusqu'à
Vladivostock mais plus de la moitié de
notre production est vendue sur notre
propre marché dans des grandes surfaces
un bilan contrasté qui fait craindre une
victoire des eurosceptiques voire des
antiuropéens dimanche prochain en
Allemagne les militants d'un nouveau
parti l'alternative pour l'Allemagne é
queuré d'un euro qui détruit l'Europe
selon eux affirment viser l'entrée au
Parlement de Bruxelles pour pour en
finir avec la politique européenne des
partis établis comme ils disent
direction l'Italie devant un millier de
militants BP Grillo leader du mouvement
5 étoiles est apparu à Bologne enflammé
il dénonce la super puissance des
banques et promet l'abolition du pacte
budgétaire européen il propose aussi un
référendum pour sortir l'Italie de
l'euro nous proposerons un référendum
pour que les citoyens décident s'ils
veulent être dans l'euro ou
pas
et cela ne veut pas dire sortir de
l'Europe il y a déjà neu pays européens
qui sont en Europe sans être dans
l'euro enfin l'Espagne malgré la crise
et un chômage à 26 % l'extrême droite
elle reste marginale ici divisée en
partie absorbé par le Parti populaire au
pouvoir elle n'espère pas obtenir le
moindre siège d'eurodéputé son discours
a du mal à passer dans un pays encore
marqué par la dictature franquiste ici
les europhobes risquent d'obtenir des
scores très éloignés de ceux du front
national
français voilà nous ont rejoint sur ce
plateau Amandine Crespi bonjour vous
êtes politologue à l'Université Libre de
Bruxelles à vos côté Griselda Pastor
bonjour vous êtes la correspondante à
Bruxelles de radio cadenasser la plus
importante radio en Espagne un groupe
tout aussi important radio Pierre
Benazet bonjour vous êtes le
correspondant de Radio France à bruell
alors vous venez de voir ce petit sujet
avec cette
vague des des partis un peu europhobes
eurosceptiqu est-ce que le Parlement
européen va pas orienter ses
préoccupations virer plus à droite
droite ça dépendra évidemment du score
final hein il y a eu des des évaluations
un petit peu contrastés des sondages on
a dit que les eurosceptiques si on met
tous les groupes ensemble pourrait avoir
éventuellement jusqu'à 1/3 des sièges
mais bon il faudra voir effectivement
les résultats et les groupements
notamment l'attitude de UKIP après les
les
élections sera assez important dans tous
les cas il y aura le parti europhobe en
Grande Bretagne oui dans tous les cas il
y aura un changement d'ambiance je pense
ça c'est sûr au Parlement européen et
une obligation de de prendre en compte
des forces qui vont freiner toute
nouvell initiativ visant à plus
d'intégration j'ai l'impression que le
principal impact du vote eurosceptique
serait si ces partis arrivent à
s'entendre entre eux justement pour un
groupement arriver à faire un groupe
avec suffisamment de pays représentés
suffisamment d'eurodéputés au Parlement
européen pour avoir un groupe pour avoir
aussi quelqu'un qui représenté à la
Conférence des Présidents et donc
influer sur l'ordre du jour influer sur
l'agenda du Parlement européen c'est là
que le le réel impact pourrait se faire
sentir vous pensez que c'est pas une
menace parce qu'ils sont divisés ils
sont ils seront de toute façon divisés à
un moment ou un autre ils arriveront
peut-être à s'entendre au début il est
très probable qu'au bout de quelques
mois ou quelques années dans le pire des
cas euh ce genre de groupement se
retrouve à éclater pour moi le le
principe c'est pas le problème de ce de
ces groupes politiques ne sera pas dans
ces parlements mais c'est son influence
dans les capitales donc c'est pas un
phénomène général dans l'Union mais ils
ont une influence terrible dans chaque
capitale croissante et bien sûr qui a un
impact direct sur la politique des gros
partis européens c'est ça le problème de
mon point de vue pour pour citer un
dernier sondage pour près de 8 Français
sur 10 les institutions européennes sont
trop éloignées des préoccupations
quotidiennes des gens il a une méfiance
grandissante vis-à-vis d'une Europe dont
beaucoup considèrent qu'elle n'a pas
rempli sa mission d'amener la prospérité
protéger contre le chômage ça c'est pour
l'exemple le le français est-ce que
c'est pas ça qui va traduire finalement
dans les ures dimanche prochain is c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est comme ça les
sondages ont raison les opinions
réflètent ce qui s'est passé les chages
à Grandé et on s'en est eniché un peu
donc oui c'est vrai mais c'est l'examen
qu'ils vont passer malheureusement le
système ne permet pas que ceux qui ont
pris les décisions passent l'examment
d'une façon directe donc on est un peu
confronté à la première campagne le
premier essai de campagne électorale
chose magnifique à niveau européen on
doit accepter qu'il y a un examen qui va
se faire l'examament est sur la crise le
résultat on verra moi je crois que le
principal problème va être l'abstention
que c'est là où on devrait se poser quel
est le seil d'abstention que le système
peut se permettre l'abstention c'est ce
qu'on craint c'est quoi c'est ça va être
un vote un vote défouloir dimanche
prochain ça sera probablement le plus
gros gagnant de ce scrutin l'abstention
dans beaucoup de pays j'ai l'impression
même une majorité l'abstention va être
largement au-delà de de 50 % euh au
Pays-Bas ils seront peut-être même à 60
% d'abstention en France on on cite des
chiffres qui sont quasiment identiques
alors oui l'abstention effectivement et
puis dans beaucoup de pays que ce soit
justement au Pays-Bas ou en France il y
a pas d'implication nationale directe il
y a pas d'enjeu national direct dans ces
élections donc c'est très facile de
parler du traité de des négociations du
traité de libre échange avec les
États-Unis c'est très facile de parler
euh des plans d'austérité des de la
gestion financière de l'Europe et de
créer des craintes et de créer des chez
les électeurs une volonté de dénoncer la
façon dont ça se passe aussi h CR oui il
y a je pense un problème dans les deux
sens c'est-à-dire que d'une part il y a
sans doute un problème de fonctionnement
démocratique des institutions
européennes où effectivement les
responsables ceux qui prennent les
décisions ne peuvent pas
systématiquement être sanctionnés par la
logique électorale et le vote et donc
forcément ça nourrit l'éloignement
l'indifférence et dans l'autre sens il y
a aussi un énorme problème de
connaissance tout simplement on dit
l'Europe est loin mais il y a peu
d'information qui redescend je dirais de
Bruxelles via les responsables nationaux
via les médias nationaux sur le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes dont on dit toujours
qu'elles sont complexes mais par exemple
les institutions américaines sont
également très complexes et ça n'empêche
pas à la à la démocratie de de
fonctionner mais il y a pas un problème
d'information de mon fin de moi j'en
suis désolée je fais tellement de papier
par jour non mais c'est pas un problème
d'information c'est un problème de prise
de décision c'est un problème de mépris
face au citoyens c'est un problèmeme
politiques on tendance à nationaliser
les succès
européens excusez-moi nous ceux qui
travaillent ici on la tendance à
mépriser mais oui ce qui prennent les
décisions qui sont dans les postes
méprisés c'est une faute de mépris ce
qu'ils ont par rapport à ceux qui vont
subir les décisions qu'ils ont donc d'un
côté les conseils se cachent oui c'est
vrai d'autre côté il y a des gens qui
ont accepté d'être représentants dans
les institutions pour gérer la politique
européenne qui ne font pas son travail
en tenant compte des Européens c'est
tout il s'explique pas au moins dernier
mot il a quand même peut-être un
problème de couverture médiatique moi
pour ces élections-ci c'est très
différent c'est la première fois que
l'élection aura un impact sur le choix
du président donc on verra probablement
plutôt en 2019 quel sera le résultat de
ces élections-ci mais je me rappelle de
celle de 2009 où il y avait des
élections au États-Unis présidentielle
juste avant on entendait beaucoup dans
les rédactions parisiennes loin d'ici
dire que c'était plus facile de couvrir
les États-Unis que de couvrir l'Europe
qui était beaucoup trop compliqué et un
peu moins un peu moins amusante un peu
moins sexy un peu moins voyez la
caricature est toujours plus facile et
plus amusante et passe mieux à la
télévision ou à la radio écoutez la N
justement pierre bénazé vous parliez du
traité
trans atlantique il fait on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment il fait peur c'est
le grand méchant marché on regarde ce
petit sujet on réagit juste après
pr ironie du calendrier à quelques jours
des élections européennes les
négociateurs européens et américains se
sont retrouvés à Washington c'est la 5e
fois qu'ils se rencontrent à H clos pour
élaborer le traité
transatlantique un accord de libre
échange entre les États-Unis 315
millions d'habitants et l'Union
européenne 500 millions un marché sans
barrière qui représente 40 % du commerce
mondial s'il est signé ce traité
concernera l'agriculture l'industrie
l'énergie les produits chimique la santé
mais aussi les appellations comme
Rockfort ou champagne dans notre vie
quotidienne le traité transatlantique
aura ces sûr de nombreuses conséquences
ces détracteurs affirment que les
États-Unis exporteront chez nous leurs
poulet désinfectés au chlore leurs
fruits et légumes au GM et surtout leur
bœf aux hormones pour le commissaire
européen qui traite avec ton ce sont des
mensonges pas question d'apporter des
OGM il l'a redit devant le Parlement
européen problème les discussions sur le
traité entre les États-Unis et l'Europe
manquent de transparence certes il est
difficile d'obtenir des informations sur
leurs avancements mais c'est une
discrétion indispensable selon le
commissaire européen un certain degré de
confidentialité nécessaire pour rendre
les négociations possible lorsqu'un
accord sera trouvé entre Washington et
Bruxelles s'ils y arrivent le traité
transatlantique dev re validé par le
Parlement européen ce sera le premier
dossier à Fort en jeu des nouveaux
élus voilà question toute simple à mes
invités est-ce qu'on va manger bientôt
du poulet au chlore moi parce que je
mange presque pas de viande ça je peux
vous le dire non le problème de ça c'est
négocier avec quelqu'un c'est toujours
important parvenir à des accords c'est
magnifique on est en crise c'est un
objectif mais il y a une terrible
tendance à niveau européen à prioriser
les intérêts des États-Unis chaque fois
qu'on les rencontre donc franchement ça
fait peur parce que ce traité est très
très très large mais euh on pourrait
vous répondre à un marché de 40 millions
euh euh de qui représente 40 % euh du du
marché mondial c'est c'est c'est jackpot
quoi on peut non oui oui oui ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut pas rénoncer et que
ce qu'on a vit jusqu'à présent à de
grand choses et toutes petites choses
donc euh quand il y a des Américains qui
arrivent l'Union se fait c'est minuscule
et c'est pour ça que c'est traités Ben a
des problèmes quand même 28 états
derrièreauunanimité politique est
difficile à obtenir le mandat de
négociation a été difficile à négocier
le mandat de négociation est pas public
on sait pas exactement ce qu'il y a
dedans on s'est excité beaucoup dans
certains pays sur des parties du traité
on s'est excité beaucoup en France sur
l'exception culturelle qui finalement ne
sera pas dedans à priori en tout cas de
ce qu'on en sait pour l'instant en
revanche sur des sujets beaucoup plus
importants on n pas nous journalistes
accès à ces négociations on n pas accès
au mandat on sait pas ce qui se passe on
sait combien de reprises on sait que
c'est la 5ème reprise des négociations
mais ce qui a été acquis pour l'instant
en réalité on sait pas sur le fond on va
parler plutôt de normes que de droit de
douane mais ces normes c'est extrêmement
important un impact ceux qui comprennent
pas c'est qu'est-ce qu'il a à
l'intérieur de ce traité transatlantique
c'est quoi c'est il a de barrières les
barrières douanières elles existent déjà
quasiment plus il y a quasiment plus de
droit de douane à part sur les plus
barrières normative alors chage ça sera
sur les normes ça sera sur les normes de
production les les normes pour les
automobiles est que les les voitures
doivent avoir un phare carré ou rond
pour vendre plus facilement son
automobile en Allemagne et aux
États-Unis sans changer de modèle de
phare par exemple ce genre de choses on
a parlé des poulets à la dioxine des
poulets aux hormones des du BF aux
hormones et cetera ça ce sont des normes
les Européens n'en veulent absolument
pas il y a peu de chance que ça passe la
rampe à mon sens mais mais il y a
beaucoup d'autres sujets il y a des
milliards de normes en Europe et aux
États-Unis qu'on veut par ces
négociations harmonisé le problème c'est
qu'on n pas et les les États-membres non
plus n'ont pas d'accès direct à
les États-Unis ont demandé à la
Commission européenne de rien publier
donc on ne sait pas grand-chose sur ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de ces
négociations et donc effectivement là
c'est un vrai sujet opaque c'est un vrai
sujet qui peut facilement être dénoncé
par des eurosceptiques et même des gens
qui sont favorables à l'Europe peuvent
être défavorables à ces négociations
amine CRPI un problème juridique aussi
de de conflit de conflit avec les
tribunaux arbitraux privés donc qui vont
poser des États aux multinationales
c'est un traité extrêmement large donc
il a toute une série de d'enjeux
effectivement c'est l'opacité qui qui
alimente qui alimente les peurs sur le
fond on a parfois un petit peu de mal à
comprendre puisqueeffectivement on nous
dit qu'il y a énormément de commerce à
développer d'argent à faire avec la
suppression des normes différentes et
d'autre part on nous dit que non non
rien ne va changer et que les normes
auxquelles nous européens nous tenons en
matière de sécurité d'environnement et
cetera ne vont pas changer je crois que
la motivation qui est derrière ce traité
c'est l'idée de constituer un bloc
commercial économique de l'ouest de
l'Occident face aux puissances
émergentes et ça pose la question de
savoir si effectivement américains et
européens se rejoignent partout sur les
mêmes valeurs qui peuvent se traduire
dans une harmonisation en Europe on a le
principe de précaution c'est-à-dire si
c'est pas sûr on interdit aux États-Unis
c'est l'inverse c'est si c'est pas si on
n pas la preuve que c'est dangereux on
laisse aller est-ce que ça va pas
s'opposer qu'fronté pour moi le problème
c'est qu'on peut on risque d'être avalé
par quelqu'un dont les normes jouent
toujours à sa faveur et souvent contre
les nôtrrees donc on peut pas négliger
qu'on ouvre les négociations après
toutes l' affaire des écoutes dont on en
parle plus sans avoir reçu aucune
réponse sans être sûr de qu'on a des
garanties qu'on sera respecté je veux
dire c'est franchement ça quand on le
mélange avec l'opacité dont vous parlez
ça moi ça me fait certain perd donc bon
il faut attendre un peu voir si quelque
chose peut changer avec la nouvelle
Commission européenne parce que c'est
toujours une chance on a toujours la
possibilité d'attendre que ça puiss
changer la façon de gérer ça est-ce que
vous pensez que comme pense C ces
détracteurs ce traité c'est une arme de
destruction massive lancée par José
Manuel
Baroso arme de destruction massive de
l'idée européenne à quelques jours du
crutin qui plus est ce qui est certain
en tout cas c'est que ça va prendre très
longtemps avant d'aboutir si jamais ça
aboutit c'est la troisième fois que les
États-Unis et l'Europe essayent de
lancer un traité de ce type une zone de
libre échange de ce type les deux fois
précédentes ça a été un flop intégral
cette fois-ci on va plus loin un peu
dans la négociation il y a aucune
certitude que ça va aboutir certains
disait en printemps 2015 on aura des
résultats parmi les négociateurs
beaucoup disent qu'on verra pas quoi que
ce soit avant 2016 et toutes les
occasion que ça achope sont présentes à
chaque reprise des négociations là c'est
la 5e dans les grandes précédentes je
pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'énervement
déjà tout de suite direction l'Espagne
des étudiants en colère contre la
politique d'austérité à Madrid
l'éducation nationale touché de plein
fouet là-bas la politique de rigur c'est
c'est des bourses en moins ça fait
sortir les étudiants dans la rue
regardez le reportage de Jean-Baptiste
Daoulas à Madrid la contestation s'écrit
sur les murs des universités déjà une
quinzaine de grèves organisé en 2 ans
des frais d'inscription qui explosent
des bourses de plus en plus difficiles à
obtenir les universités espagnoles sont
au bord de
l'asphyie Juliette est l'une des
victimes de l'austérité dans l'éducation
étudiante en 4e année boursière elle vit
chez ses parents dans la banlieu de
Madrid et sa situation financière s'est
détériorée en quelques mois jusqu'à
présent pour ma 2e et ma troè année
d'étude j'avais eu droit à une bourse
qui couvrait les frais d'inscription de
l'université donc qui en plus ont
augmenté d'une année sur l'autre et
j'avais droit à environ 1150 € à chaque
fois pour tout ce qui était abonnement
transport matériel cours de langue et
cetera et cette année je n'ai eu droit à
aucune des deux choses le gouvernement
conservateur a durci l'accès aux bourses
avec des critères économiques mais aussi
une obligation de résultat très stricte
conséquence près de 20000 étudiants ont
perdu leur bourse l'an
dernier mes parents mes grands-parents
et les générations de gens qui ont
travaillé dans ce pays ont payer leurs
impôts pour que leurs enfants et leurs
petits-enfants aient droit à une
éducation et on va pas laisser qu'on
nous la vole nous nouvelle journée de
manifestation dans le quartier du Prado
avec leur t-shirt vert des étudiants ont
monté un collectif contre l'austérité
comme Juliette ils sont nombreux à subir
la réforme des
bourses on ne m'a toujours pas versé ma
bourse et on est déjà au mois de mai les
cours se terminent donc si c'est une
bourse pour étudier mais qui est versée
après les cours ça n'a pas vraiment
d'utilité ma bourse a été réduite
significativement d'environ 50 % comme
j'ai pas eu 6 moyenne sur 10 retir ma
bourse en Espagne le budget de
l'Éducation nationale représentait 4,9%
du produit intérieur brut en 2010 un
chiffre que le gouvernement veut ramener
à 3,9% d'ici 2015 c'est 10 milliards
d'euros en moins pour
l'éducation l'ustérité en coupant dans
d'autres secteurs mais pas dans
l'éducation la dépendance ou encore la
santé tous ces services et ces droits
essentiel pour les citoyens que le
gouvernement du Parti populaire de
Marian ro est en train de
raboter autre cible de l'austérité le
programme Erasmus qui permet de partir
étudier à l'étranger un drame pourilio
Garcia Pretto l'un des fondateurs du
programme en
Espagne de toutes les choses que j'ai
faites dans ma carrière c'est celle qui
m'a donné le plus de satisfaction j'ai
connu beaucoup de jeunes qui ont fait
Erasmus et pas un seul ne m'a dit qu'il
avait perdu son temps ou qu'il
regrettait désormais pour obtenir une
bourse du gouvernement les Espagnols
devront maîtriser la langue du pays
d'accueil avant de partir l'effet est
dissuasif pour la première fois depuis
1987 le nombre de boursiers Erasmus est
en
baisse il y a un choix éducatif très
clair on nous dit que la bonne éducation
est pour ceux qui ont les moyens
économiques et que les autres doivent se
contenter d'une éducation basique et
puis c'est
tout c'est un changement radical par
rapport au passé où l'on a fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour que les personnes sans
beaucoup de moyens puissent aller aussi
loin que leur permettent leur capacité
on est en train de vivre une tragédie
dans ce
pays l'austérité est douloureuse mais
l'économie espagnole se redresse peu à
peu le pays est sorti de la récession en
2013 voilà reportage signé Jean-Baptiste
daouasespagne sort de la récession pas
de la crise c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle Griselda Pastor est-ce que
c'est pas ça qui va faire des dégâs
dimanche prochain cette politique
d'austérité que les gens forcément ne
comprennent pas tous forcémentcz je vais
vous dire que la bonne nouvelle ça sera
le jour où le chômage on le verra
vraiment rétrécir et ça c'est pas le cas
donc franchement de bonnes nouvelles
sortir de la récession ça ne veit rien
dire pour le quotidien de gens là on a
vu les étudiants mais il faut pas
oublier les immigrés qui ont perdu le
droit à la santé publique qui est
gratuite en Espagne encore il faut pas
oublier les enfants qui n'ont plus le
droit de manger dans les écoles il y a
il y a un rapport incroyable où tous les
exemples sont rassemblés du défenseur de
droits de l'homme de Strasbourg
justement que je recommande à tout le
monde de le lire c'est effrayant de voir
comment cette crise a détruit tout les
bases d'une société démocratique donc
j'ai pas il y a pas longtemps j'ai passé
par Grèce tout ce qui est assistant
social tout ce que l'État devrait faire
est en train d'être fait par des ONG et
des associations parallèles franchement
c'est la fin du système je vous le dis
c'est très grave ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est politique d'austérité
c'est ça qui
euh c'est ça qui tue l'Europe dans
beaucoup de pays essentiellement du du
sud de l'Europe enfin je veux dire quand
vous regardez les taux de chômage des
jeunes qui sont au-delà de 50 % dans
certains pays euh dont la Grèce par
exemple quand vous regardez euh la
récession effectivement la moyenne
européenne selon les derniers chiffres
la les déficits sont en dessous de 3 %
on est plus dans la récession
effectivement il y a eu un impact des
politiques d'austérité et les dirigeants
européens actuels s'en félicitent
d'accord mais pour l'instant c'est
uniquement des chiffres
macro-économiques qui ont pas d'impact
sur la vie réelle des gens et c'est les
gens votent sur ce qu'ils connaissent
les gens votent pas sur des politiques
budgétaires à long terme les gens votent
pas euh comme on votait pas autrefois
sur le serpent monétaire européen les
critères de convergence de Maastricht on
vote sur ce qu'on reçoit dans sa feuille
de paye on vote sur ce qu'on reçoit au
chômage et c'est pour ça qu'on vote
essentiellement au Pays-Bas pour
hvilders c'est pour ça qu'on votera
essentiellement en France pour Marine Le
Pen enfin les partis qui vont arriver
premiers à ces élection là pas d'enjeu
national direct mais un enjeu
anti-européen très clair oui ça c'est
certain l'Espagne elle a bénéficié de
beaucoup d'Aid c'est peut-être aussi ça
qu'il a qu' lui a permis de sortir de la
de la récession comme on a dit elle sort
de la récession mais pas de non mais
franchement excuse moi mais non l'aide a
été pour la banque alors pour les
banques vous faites la différence pas
pour franchement donc non non non le
problème de tout ça c'est comment
exprimer cette malaise dans le système
européens sans tomber disons sur des
groupes ultra radicales non et comment
pouvoir voter pour des groupes qui ne
sont pas les majoritaires sans que
personne te dise que tu es contre
l'Union européenne parce que des facto
en Espagne vous l'avez dit il y a pas
d'ultr droite mais quand même la
tendance de toute la campagne c'est de
dire que tu ne votes pas ou pour le PP
ou pour le PSC bon tu es quelqu'un qui
est contre l'Union et ça franchement
c'est en plus de ce que train de souir
c'est absolument inacceptable vous voyez
bien les partis d'extrême gauche en
Espagne pourrait profiter detrême gauche
extrême gauche disons je sais pas ce que
vous comprenez ou vous entendez
partrme ça c'est pas l'extrême gauche j'
suis désolé l'extrême gauche Ctait C qui
prenaient la lutte armée il y en a pas
dans cette crise de gens qui prendent ça
alors franchement nous il y a une gauche
il y a une gauche plus radicale qu'une
autre mais mais j'ai l'espoir de que
tout le monde puisse voter ce qu'il veut
et qu'après on essaie d'arriver à un
accord avec ce qu'on aura quoi un
commentaireine Cresp je crois que le cas
espagnol reflète bien la myopie
politique qui accompagne les politiques
d'austérité c'est-à-dire qu'on cherche à
tout prix à rétablir une situation
budgétaire à récupérer 01 02 point de
croissance mais en
empêchant tout investissement dans
l'avenir d'une société et d'une économie
et c'est ça qui est en train de se
passer dans à peu près tous les pays
européens pas uniquement
en Espagne ça fait 10 ans qu'on nous dit
que la compétitivité de l'Europe c'est
l'économie de la connaissance qu'il faut
faire de l'investissement sociale dans
l'éducation dans la santé et cetera et
on voit que c'est tout le contraire
cette économie de la connaissance
n'existe pas l'investissement social est
un agenda politique qui est aujourd'hui
au point mort qui est promis par la
Commission européenne mais qui n'a pas
vu le début d'une mise en œuvre tout
simplement parce qu'on refuse de
consacrer le moindre euros à des
investissements d'avenir et pour donc
les pays à voter pour à voter dimanche
les états rivalisent d'imagination avec
des spots publicitaires regarder l'un
d'eux il nous vient du Danemark avec un
personnage votman c'est plutôt TR
regardez
voilà ce genre de spot publicitaire
c'est efficace Pieraz en tout cas ça
marque les esprits pr et c'est pas
forcément une mauvaise chose je sais pas
exactement quel est le niveau
d'abstention moyen au Danemark mais on
sait très bien que il y a des pays même
en France pays fondateur de l'Union
européenne il y a des gens encore
aujourd'hui qui ont pas réalisé qu'il
avoir qu'il allit avoir un seul tour à
ces élections contrairement des
législatives en France donc
effectivement oui un seul tour à la
proportionnelle franchement en Espagne
c'est qui a marqué le esprit c'est une
déclaration du candidat du Parti
populaire qui a l'espoir de devenir
commissaire en justifiant sa mauvaise
performance pendant les débats
électorals parce que vous voyez débattre
avec indam c'était la candidate
socialiste ça force toujours les hommes
à se retenir en paix pour ne pas disons
montrer un peu la supériorité alors je
peux vous dire ça a marqué les esprits
mais je suis sûr que lui il a perdu
beaucoup de voix alors bon cet expit je
sais pas quoi vous dire un mot sur ces
clips publicitaires oui peut-être que la
communication un petit peu trash permet
au moins d'informer les les gens qui les
voient qu' y a une élection que c'est
important de se mobiliser après je crois
que plus sérieusement les jeunes aussi
peut-être oui peut-être mais il est
vieux ce type il est vieux il est
démandé non non c'est il est pas gêne
quoi dans les spot c lui qui sort c'est
une image démodée c'est ce qu'on ne veut
pas dans l'Union je veux dire c'est
incroyable bon je sais pas moi je suis
un peu peut-être que ça marchera en
Danmark ou ben alors qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire si des valeurs pareilles sont
ceux qui font aller les gens voter avec
un type là avec tous ces B tu vois ou
non donc la photo de du mal des années 4
en Espagne bon je sais pas quoi te dire
mais c'est pas pour ça on verra on se
donne rendez-vous tous dimanche prochain
dès 19h30 sur les chaînes parlementaires
pour une grande soirée électorale restez
avec nous d'ici là bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires